[Applause]
hello conan hey how are you good to see
you okay
okay stop sit down
okay hello great how are you nice to see
you here
very nice to see you so um we'll talk
about what's going on here in just a
second of course
uh this is cement you know cement this
is solid give it
a little tap this is real cement and i
will testify to that it feels good for
him when you tap it there's a lot of
differences yeah that's clearly very
erotic for him yeah
let's talk about the special the special
special it's a series
a whole damn series it's gonna run
forever it's gonna
it'll never end it'll go and go and go
because we're the the name of the show
is penn and teller bull
and we're exposing both and when you are
deciding to mine the fertile fields of
bull
you've got a career forever it's going
to go forever
why would that stop or
you know it's too bad penn teller's show
on showtime was wonderful but then
everyone stopped lying and they're out
of a job that's not going to happen
we're safe forever
well you see you're on cable we are not
so we won't mention the title anymore
because it's on a different network
exactly
you can't say another shut the [ __ ] up
[Applause]
no you can't no that's a dirty word here
don't blip it but
have fun yeah we'll build with that now
we should probably talk about what
this is a publicity stunt is it it's
working
it's working we want to show that
everyone in america is watching
every single human being every single
human being because of our publicity
stunt you see david blaine
does nothing he gets buried he gets
buried in the box for seven days
he does nothing he got frozen in ice
does nothing right and he stands in a
pole and does nothing
so we thought we don't have enough money
for tether to do absolutely nothing for
seven days or
a week or something but we have plenty
for him to just put a block in his head
for
let's call that a month it hasn't been a
month let's call let's call it a year
he's been in this block for a year swear
to god
he's been in this block for a year he
can't eat he can barely
breathe he's sucking wind up his neck
now
which means something in irish yeah so
uh so
so he's encased in here yeah he's
encased in concrete he's been in here
for a long time can he hear us
right now can you hear us yes he can
hear us
okay and uh this is get and also because
you know david blaine has a lot of money
behind him
he can just do nothing but we found that
teller still has to do stuff while he's
in there
so tell his been doing a card want to
see a car trick in there he's going to
do a card trick
quality cement you know when you say
card trick america answers they love to
see card tricks
a card trick with his head in case he's
cemented i don't think it's ever been
done
uh well we didn't when you saw it stop
okay
and it went well you liked it you said
that i don't know what you're talking
about
i arrived here it is now almost one
o'clock in the morning
he had that on his head for let's call
it five years
okay for five years for over 14 years
this is over cement
i don't think i've ever seen you before
and i have no idea what's going to
happen
oh yeah he's running out of air however
long it's been
it's been too long okay he's gonna do a
card trick tell her
time for the card trick oh sorry he's
all set there's the deck of cards
okay now what he's gonna do is he's just
he's gonna do this all himself show the
cards to the people tell her
show that they're all different okay
that's fine show them to conan
show them okay don't show them to conan
over here hey
all those cards are different right now
he's just going to deal through them
uh and you're going to just say stop
whenever you whenever the hell you
choose
i can just say whenever any time yeah
you're going to get the next card
whenever you go a little faster it's
going too slow you go and go faster
okay and i'm just going to say uh
stop okay you want the next one now do
you want to go further because you can
go further okay let's go a little
further
because i don't want you to cry baby and
i wanted to go further
when do you want to stop uh stop okay
that one right there
there's this one this one right here
okay right that one right there yeah
okay now tell's gonna show that to the
the audience but more than that and this
is the part that's so
amazing conan he's going to tear off a
corner of it
and give it to you he's going to give
you part of the card he's tearing off
the
corner now okay and uh now give give
conan give conan part of the give no you
want to give give conan
this part the little part little part
and see then they match up in the corner
so you have that right there right there
and then what you're gonna do is we're
gonna vanish this okay now as i said on
our tv show
on showtime i said it um
we're exposing all these frauds and
stuff so we do a little bit of voodoo
get out the tongs he's got the tongs i
want to show you this vanish this is a
vanish
does he just always carry tongs of
course don't you okay
pull out your tongs
okay good close the tongs there we go
now see this is going to vanish in a
mysterious voodoo way
it's vanishing now you can almost see it
melting yeah before your very eyes yeah
that's really mysterious voodoo you're
doing there buddy
it's vanishing no the the voodoo part
comes later
it's totally vanished this is something
we were studying all these stupid occult
sciences we came up with this now watch
the magic transference
as the spirit of the ash moves through
the concrete
do that special move teller see that's
that's just a beautiful thing
he's on fire it's all right
it's all right he he kind of likes it
now we're gonna this is what will be the
punch line oh you're gonna love you
wanna you know after you see this you're
gonna know why he wants this
because if i didn't put this over him
he'd be madder than a wet hem
we're gonna get you out in a second now
watch this because this is the big
reveal
you're gonna watch this closely on uh uh
friday night
uh eleven o'clock show time we got a
show called
well you know what it's called is that
better come on you want to be coy
here we go and here's your here's your
card call in
oh it's it's supposed to oh oh wow
okay oh sorry that's okay that just hit
me in the face
uh oh and conan
is that's your card right there is that
your card right there
oh my god the card match up the corner
there
look at that it's pretty amazing that
hidden that is pretty amazing that's
exactly
right that's exactly
perfect all right thank you very much
excellent penn and teller
you know we're talking about premieres
tomorrow night at 11. on showtime
everybody